our most anticipated pc games of 2017 i
want to start with Mass Effect Andromeda
again this isn't the only platform it's
releasing on but I think it's the one
that like most of us will play it on
just in terms of a graphical fidelity
and whatnot Jake you're a huge mass
effect fan what are you excited for most
with Andromeda I am most excited for a
return to sort of the RPG roots that the
series is kind of known for it sounds
like they're taking that and they're
expanding on that even bigger like the
planet diversity is a lot lot more
planet there's a lot more diverse
planets there's a lot more room to
explore the Mako all the Mako isn't back
its but there is a ground vehicle you
can use to explore my I mean I I'm super
excited for this game I can ramble about
this for a long time yeah so for those
who aren't I haven't been following it
feverishly you play as either Sarah or
Scott writer just pick your gender and
go with it as like it replaces commander
shepard your stand on the Andromeda
initiative obviously it's like our
closest neighboring galaxy despite the
fact that it's still how many
light-years away I forget I did an
entire article on it like what science
tells us about the Andromeda galaxy
we're supposed to mesh like how far in
the future yeah there's now essentially
there's a super collision that's gonna
happen and it's in crazy yeah it's just
it's tomorrow yeah the drama galaxies
just honored doorstep that's crazy
actually like I was reading up on it a
lot I did way too much research for this
like 800 word article but apparently
when these galaxies start colliding and
absorbing each other the suns will form
a black hole at the center but each
individual planet in the solar system is
so far apart from the next they won't
collide at all in fact like it will be
it won't even affect each other that
much the gravitational pull won't affect
so just be this massive galaxies as form
and then everything will get sucked in
the black holes and then shot into like
other dimensions essentially like at
such high speeds and decisions that like
they're not gonna be planted see more
they're gonna be as rocks floating so
earth while earth itself will just like
I'll survive you guys probably won't but
not just kidding my shoes but yeah also
like a big difference with like you said
they're going back to RPG roots the
first mass effect did have more those as
a post like to which was kind of RPG /
third-person cover-based shooters three
I felt one more toward action yeah I
mean they did bring back some of the RPG
elements for three but it was like it's
the head like giant set pieces the
explosions and stuff like that yeah and
but what makes mass effect at least why
I love mass effects so much of the quiet
moments like when you're on your ship
when you're talking to people and it
sounds like they are doubling down on
that like there's different I mean
you're gonna have there's like the ship
the tempest which you can explore and
then there's another ship the arc which
is sort of like the hub area in this
game and it sounds like they'll be
plenty of those character-driven moments
which is what I'm looking forward to the
tempest is your Normandy for all intents
purchase right yeah so it's the
replacement of the Normandy and then the
Nomad is the social the Nomad is the
replacement of the misc oh sorry gonna
make sweet hot love to aliens with
problem technical hopefully there is
also the fact that you don't have to
pick between those three classes or
three hybrid classes at the beginning
you just start as Sarah our sky rider
and then just build out your skills
however you want them it's almost like a
what's the run in the dark souls 2 and
dark souls 3 the dark souls series where
you're deprived runs where you start
with like no skills no pre like no
predetermined path you can just build
how everyone probably that's how
Andromeda is gonna be more along yes I
actually I wouldn't be surprised it
seems like the way it's going but then
like jean-loup could actually do like a
trailer breakdown and if you notice like
classes would have different color
shields at least in the main game or at
least in one two and three or two and
three and then in this one like the
shields are different sometimes
sometimes they're blue sometimes they're
purple that's just like a little detail
but um that's yeah I don't know the
that's the thing this what has met me
most excited for this game actually it's
just because I mean the first one was
more of an RPG right but it also still
felt pretty clunky like I loved how to
kind of took that those third-person
elements and you know cover based
shooting and made that you know let me
enjoy those quieter moments more because
the combat wasn't so frustrating and the
Makos coming back like you said but I
don't know if I want that like if they
can make it fun like I know there are
people that just love the Mako I can't
I hated the make on the first one but it
I mean it seems like they're taking the
steps they need to make this Mako or
nomads actually pilot like it should
yeah like it should and I would argue
though that you didn't hate the Mako you
hated the Baron boring planet or the
like fortresses you had to assault the
head like six turrets on this right when
you go through every room with six
terrace was just uh crates inside of it
right and there's one like new helmet
you got yeah i would i would like I mean
you know just just dreams but I would
really like that ability like I think to
kind of did a lot of that where you were
I thought was cool was like just probing
a planet like I have no problem having
that like no man sky boring ass planet
as long as you don't have to land on it
right yeah like if there was the
solution of like hey this is actually a
pretty habitable or blush planet with
like a you know a bunch of crogans on it
cool now i can i can no I know that if I
land there I could spend a lot of time
there and talk to people and get stories
and stuff like that that direction was
like what i love about to yeah i don't
want to land on like Andromeda's version
of north dakota no offense the viewers
in north dakota it just doesn't seem
like as much going on in a lot of that
state we're like Antarctica exactly that
would be a less offensive ones like know
what movie planet no man sky yeah no
that's harsh yeah we all just took digs
at certain states and games um alright
moving on from that this one I'm
actually really excited for I don't know
if either you guys have played Division
II original sin let me restart that
divinity original sin divinity original
sent to from Larian Studios II Belgian
developers releasing next year I played
a bunch of previous game I love the
first one it's actually it's not
underrated people praised it very very
highly it was gamespot's pc game of the
year two years ago 2014 from that
mistaken and then it's just isometric
like old-school western RPG party based
combat and exploration it ill and then
the combat becomes turn-based but if you
guys are into that at all you should
play the first one to get ready for this
because this game looks unreal actually
like full disclosure kevin van noord
former reviews editor you spot is well
writing helping write this game I'm you
know like it's a fantasy RPG and there's
also like pvp elements to this which
didn't sound like anything I wanted but
I played a few previews actually really
fun like it's you get three characters
against three and it's oh no you get one
versus one they might be introducing new
maps but you get a like like a these
lizard characters of like a new undead
class thats in this game as you're
building at your party and then you can
you know like the calm and this game is
awesome it's all experimentation based
and all kind of like a cause and effect
right like so there's this barrel up on
top of the scaffolding and then knowing
this mage is better at a distance and
from a height you lob you predetermine
that you're gonna lob like a fire
grenade or a fireball onto it so then
when they go up it'll just be burning
they'll have to come down which will
allow your warrior to get up close its
I'm like kind of being reductive right
now but there are a lot of nuance and a
lot of layers to its combat that
actually makes the PvP really fun
obviously just basing this game play
right here if you play the first one you
know it can be pretty menu heavy text
heavy if you're ready if you're just
like ready to get really absorbed in a
game play the first one because it's
really rewarding the story is great the
characters are awesome and obviously
like the main character being one you're
fleshing out to looks looks fantastic
and I cannot wait for this it is yes
slated for 2017 but I hope it comes very
soon um anyway do you guys have any
thought you don't have any thoughts
about divinity I think and he played it
I keep it but if you want no no yeah now
that's sounds really excited for that
game it looks great and awesome plays
great from when I played pyar supergiant
games of Bastion and transistor fame
it's their newest game looks like a
football game at first but it's also an
RPG it's also this Thurber's and
adventure pretty fun from when i played
if you guys got an hands-on with it at
all no I've seen a lot of it I mean
stylistically and it's art style it
looks wild and like yeah just wacky and
not wacky I would say but very original
yeah you can't really a friend from the
other stuff yeah you can't really like
point at any kind of era almost I don't
even know what it is oh it's a when I'm
trying to describe the genre to people i
say imagine a turn-based combat RPG
where the combat is fantasy football and
make a big space and I don't know yeah
words where the combat is football set
in a fantasy world not fantasy football
you're not getting together to draft
people um yeah you get you three
characters to begin with I think it
expands later but of course like there's
a small one who's really gonna dashing
has extra dash and then you're just
passing this ball around trying to get
it into the other players like endzone
for all intents and purposes but then
the maps become more intricate it turns
out it's like this tournament to like
free yourself from slavery so it has
like that's radiator aspect right it's
like Russell Crowe trying to open his
shackles and whatnot but you know but
then you have like this huge story
between the others camp you go to
upgrade your characters and kind of
build new items and whatnot you know the
RPG elements in between the writing the
art styles gorgeous like even just these
characters that pop up during the
dialogue look on amazing it you could
definitely tell it's like inspired by
transition transistor and Bastion you
don't really threw me off in a really
great way that was the music i found the
music i like to have a very like
interesting contrast with like
everything that was going on because it
has a very like fantasy element to it
but like I remember hearing almost like
a like a rock distorted bass groove that
was just felt it made it feel like a
space frontier tighter type of style
yeah and it's weird because you see it
one of the more intricate maps here and
you have like the large character you
have the main one in the middle you have
the smaller one that scampers around it
becomes a little more it's like
rock-paper-scissors at first and how you
attack some with a ball or defend from
it but then it becomes more about kind
of the overarching structure that game
is really appealing to me because these
bite-sized the actual combat or the
actual events what you want to call them
sporting events that's like the the
bite-sized things that you just really
learn the intricacies of a pretty simple
game like gwent or you know like chess
which seems simple at first but then you
realize how complicated it can be but
then you have this like overarching RPG
and it's not open world you're going
from point to point a log of Matt from
what I remember and that's where like
the you know like umbrellas story comes
into play and kind of contextualize it
all and makes it memorable from a story
narrative perspective I can't
really explain it much better than that
it's weird it's like play like right
here say you're lining up a power blast
you get the ball and you just have to
carry it to their end zone without them
stopping you it's a really really fun
game nation looks so freaking cool yes
like transistor itself was almost hard
to describe two of how they approach
turn-based combat and whatnot but ya
pyar I can't wait for this supergiant
games that they haven't ever made
anything less than great so I'm looking
forward to that last thing i want to
touch on for pc title in 2017 is one
that's been ongoing for quite a while
but Robbie you finally just dug in
recently just star citizen I think
because of no man's sky and Italy
dangerous kind of piqued interest in
this I played a demo at Gamescom yeah
I'm kind of looking forward to seeing
what content they come out with see how
much closer they're getting to the ideal
vision that we all have of it yeah the
first person shooting the gravitational
like 0 d 0g combat and outer space
finding this Hoverbike going on a planet
to help your friends fight this pirate
base all seamlessly you know it just
become such a buzz word recent yes but
I'm looking forward to I don't do we
know like it specifically so yeah I mean
sometimes 2017 right this talk right now
should be like a grain of salt just
because it's like definitely like you
can definitely say it's not coming out
next year but former gamespot video
producer get Josh Shaw and I played the
other day and what they are doing is
they're they're about to launch God dang
I can't remember the patch number but
it's supposed to address a lot of the
main issues that game which is for me
having played it it's just the
optimization I mean you're looking at
like just like 10 frames a second like
it is almost unplayable but what what
does that mean I think a lot of people
don't understand me or are unsure
they've gotten pretty far so so far I
would say like you can do a lot of cool
stuff you get a general idea i mean by
no means is this even close to done i
don't think but yeah just to say wait
what yeah what you were saying is i
don't know what at the update will be
the update will exactly bring but i'm
pretty sure it's the ability to do like
two three missions with your friends
like yeah basically meet up with them
different locations across I believe
just maybe a solar solar system more
space stations to explore yeah we'll
give you many more missions in an update
three point oh three point out which is
not released yet but that's the one I
saw at Gamescom and they showed me it
like there were a few technical hitches
I remember I like rode it really
extensive preview about it but there are
a few technically inches but that was
the thing they were worried about was
the fact that this character like wasn't
holding a glass correctly it didn't look
real that's what they're worried about
at this point they're just fine-tuning
it the connection looked great granted
it was all in one room mighta been land
at that point I you were seeing like a
sick like chris Roberts and like three
people from cloud imperium games are
showing me the demo okay and I was like
so that two people on the monitors over
here someone on the main one and they
were showing me like he these two woke
up on the space station these two were
already fighting these pirates down on
this planet yeah I forgot how long away
and of course the lights be jumps for
real time not our real time but in the
game like the lights be jumps or like
calculated so they will actually take
you know like if they're going however
many light-years will still take 10
minutes to get there if you're going
that far but they were in like a
neighboring star cluster or something so
didn't take that long so they got there
saw this you know defunct pirate ship up
in orbit around this planet were there
to co-opt teammates all in the same
instance like already in a co-op game
but not on the same plan in the same
area they saw like new there on the
planet they were talking to each other
they went got this hover bike off this
ship after killing a few pirates brought
it that their ship down and then ejected
the hover bike over the atmosphere and
then they landed on the hover bike and
then I just start careening out of
control and chris Roberts saying I when
it's ready that will not happen but it
was still cool because I neighs went the
pirate bay's and help them out these
children fighting for like 20 minutes
and the other two started like woke up
grab the mission from the guy while
these two are in the planet yeah so that
that just like you know like that
mission spanning the galaxy or spanning
that solar system at least just sounds
so cool to be in a co-op game but you
were on Jupiter I was on I don't know
mercury yeah I'd be burning alive but
let's not get into the science yeah
that's really where tie right now it's
just like a couple of disjointed pieces
you know like you can only do this like
right now we last time I played was like
oh yeah you can just kind of venture out
to this
coms array and jump started with a with
a couple buddies but was funny was what
happened we had this random guy get on
the ship and we told him to like fly it
it was his name was agent Cody and Josh
I was like Asian Cody flattish if he's
like I've never floated ship this big it
was like chatting and having the time of
her life we get there pirates blow our
ship up i get a jettison to start deep
space i'm in chat saying slow and
gravity yeah like some soon come save me
some random guy was like oh i'm on my
way out took him like 10 minutes he gets
out st. pirates kill him yeah like
thanks for the try is again whatever
that's what excites me about that game
so far my you know brief experiences
it's always been like a pretty good
community it's like that many people in
it but I mean there are a lot of people
playing this this game has a lot of
money and you know it's kind of like
criticized for one's it actually gonna
be out but the thing I keep telling
people is they never promised it's ever
going to be like this retail release its
people are paying for this like pulling
out of updates you know I don't think
they're great with the time in the
updates I think they could kind of make
better or at least less concrete
promises about when they're going to
release because this was supposed to be
december from what i remember now it's
not out yet but hopefully in the next
few months like 2017 will be you know
star citizen will be closer to realizing
what that ideal vision is that we all
have for it i'm sure chris Roberts has
42 yeah but anyway cool so those are the
pc games we were most looking forward to
in 2017 if we missed any i'm sure we did
any big ones small ones mention them in
the comments below
you